>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Qi Qiu: Hi, good afternoon.
So, before we begin today's
program I would like to ask you
to please take a moment
to check your cell phones
and other electronic devices
and set them to silent.
Thank you.
And for your reference,
this afternoon's program is
being filmed for placement
on the Kluge Center website.
As well as our YouTube
and ITunes channels.
And today's lecture is
presented by the Asian Division
and the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
The Asian Division was
founded in 1928 as the division
of Chinese literature.
So, this year actually
marks 90 years anniversary
of the Asian Division.
Even though it was
firstly named the Division
of Chinese Literature, it
had started collected Chinese
and Japanese materials
and received Mongolian
and Tibetan gifts as early
as the late 19th century.
And from 1869 presentation of
933 volumes to the United States
by the Emperor of
China, the collections
of the Asian Division have
grown to represent one
of the most comprehensive
collection
of Asian language
materials in the world.
Housed in the John Adams
building across the street,
as well as off site locations.
The collection of the division
include most subject fields
and covering an area ranging
from the south Asian
subcontinent
and Southeast Asia to East Asia.
The John W. Kluge Center at
the Library of Congress exists
to help address the
challenges facing democracy
in the 21st century
by bridging the gap
between scholarship
and policy makers.
It does this by hosting
top thinkers from the world
to conduct research at the
Library's massive collections
and engage national leaders.
So for more information
about the Kluge Center,
please visit loc.gov/kluge.
So on today's program
the program is titled,
"Reading Lu Xun Through Carl
Jung: Psychological "Truth"
in Lu Xun's "The
True Story of Ah Q."
So, here is a cover
of the new book
that Dr. Carolyn Brown
has just newly published.
Brown is a former director
of the Kluge Center
from 2006 to 2014.
She held multiple positions
during her nearly 24 year career
at the Library, including
that of associate librarian
for cultural affairs, director
of area studies collections
and director of collections
and services.
Prior to coming to the Library,
she served as the associate dean
for the humanities
at Howard University.
She holds BA and MA
degrees in Asian studies
and Chinese literature
respectively
from Cornell University.
And earned a PhD in literature
at American University.
During her academic career she
published in several journals,
including "Clear and
Modern Chinese Literature
and edited Psycho-sinology:
The Universe
of Dreams in Chinese Culture."
She currently serves as a
trustee of the Fetzer institute.
Today Carolyn will discuss
her just published book
as shown here, "Reading
Lu Xun Through Carl Jung,"
which offers a unique
approach to the short stories
of the most famous modern
Chinese writer, Lu Xun.
Brown uses foundational elements
of the psychology of Carl Jung,
who with Freud was the founder
of modern western psychology,
to illuminate key structures in
the works of this great writer.
Approaching this works
from a unique direction,
Brown's lecture will
shed new light
on the psychological patterns
within Lu Xun's most famous
story, "The True Story of Ah Q."
Now please join me in
welcoming Dr. Carolyn Brown.
[ Applause ]
>> Carolyn Brown: Well,
thank you very much, Qi Qiu.
It's a real pleasure
to be invited to talk
about my new book, "Reading
Lu Xun Through Carl Jung,"
here at the Library of Congress.
Where as you know I spent most
of my professional career.
And especially to talk
about insights that arose
from viewing his most famous
story through a Xun Jung lens.
If you decide after the
lecture that you would
like to have the book or you
might decide you don't want
to have the book, but
if you decide you want
to have the book, please take
a minute to see my husband,
Tim Eastman, who can give you a
code the publisher's provided,
that will give you
a 25% discount.
So, that's definitely worth it.
Before I forget -- begin,
I would like to thank a
few people who've made the
book possible.
No book comes into
fruition on its own.
First, [foreign name] and
the staff of the staff
of the Asia Division, including
our wonderful introducer today.
The staff of the Kluge
Center that were wonderful
in helping me transition
from being a director
to being a scholar
in the center.
I must say being a scholar
in the Center turned
out even better than I said all
the years that I was director.
Really fabulous, fabulous place.
Of course, thanks
to James Billington
who granted me the office,
the former librarian.
I'd also like to thank
Mary Jane Dee and the staff
of the African Middle
eastern Division,
who offered special
accommodations
over the last year or so.
And to the other
scholars and friends
who helped bring the
book to fruition.
And I want to mention two people
who were there at the beginning
and are here at the end, my good
friend Victoria Ronna Robinson,
who just crept in the
back and my son, Michael,
who many decades ago
it seems said to me,
"If you don't finish this
book, you won't die happy."
So, I have finished it, but
I'm not planning to die.
And, of course, my
husband, Tim Eastman,
who did way too many things that
I couldn't even mention them,
but there would be
no index without Tim.
My presentation today
will follow this outline.
First, for those of you not
familiar with the author,
I will briefly introduce Lu Xun,
who really is the most important
early Chinese intellectual --
early 20th century Chinese
intellectual and writer.
Then explain what makes my
approach unique among ways
of interpreting his
modern short stories.
For those of you
unfamiliar with Carl Jung,
I will briefly sketch a
few of the fundamental,
psychological insights I've used
that are necessary
to my interpretation.
Number four, I'll draw some
examples from the true story
of "Ah Q," as a way
of demonstrating why a
psychological reading deserves a
place among the multiple more
familiar historical cultural
and biographical readings
of this masterpiece.
And finally, I will point to
other dimensions of this story,
which I argue is a deeply
insightful reflection
on the psychological
phenomena of scapegoating.
And then briefly suggest
the power that comes
from using Jung's concepts
as an interpretive lens
for delivering new insights
into Lu Xun's stories.
And we should have
time for questions.
So, first a brief introduction.
Lu Xun is a major
Chinese intellectual
of the early 20th century, he's
generally considered the founder
of modern Chinese literature
and certainly the greatest
writer of that period.
He was a central figure in
the tumultuous early decades
of that century, both a product
of the time and a person,
an agent who shaped it.
He was born in 1881,
died in 1936.
He was of that pivotal
generation that lived
through the singular
historical moment
when China was transforming
from an ancient kingdom
to a modern state.
He was a scholar, a
teacher, a journal editor
and an active participant
in the intellectual life
of Beijing and then Shanghai.
His two collections of modern
short stories, "Call to Arms"
and "Wandering,"
broke new ground
in their content and form.
And along with his essays,
addressed contemporary concerns
with penetrating insight.
Living at a time when
China was under assault
by western imperial
powers, he searched for ways
to make China stronger.
With a focus on asking what
Chinese patterns and thought
and perception might account
for what he believes was
China's insufficient response
to the challenges arising
from encounter with the west.
He is still deeply appreciated
for his penetrating critiques
of social norms and
conditions of Chinese society.
He took what was
known, familiar,
accepted without question,
looked at them in new ways
and exposed these practices
as cruel and inhumane.
He opened his reader's
eyes to seeing
and understanding in new ways.
He is still appreciated,
and this is important,
a 100 years later, he
hasn't gone out of --
his insights have not
gone out of style.
He's still appreciated for his
insights into Chinese society,
his dedication to ending the
Chinese people suffering,
his deep moral integrity and
his commitment to self-scrutiny.
Fundamental elements of his
critique still resonate today,
which is exactly 2018,
a 100 years since he
published his very first modern
short story.
His legacy is enormous.
He's -- and this is --
it's really extraordinary.
He's memorialized in museums,
his works are read in schools
across the nation, at least
they were until recently.
They've inspired paintings,
prints, drawings, plays, operas,
ballets, films and so
forth and literary sequels.
His enormous reputation
has commandeered --
has been commandeered from
the political spectrum
on both sides.
On the left, Chairman
[inaudible] praised him
as a harbinger of the
communist revolution.
And on the right, commercial
interests have created Aleutian
theme park in Beijing.
I really have to go some
time and meet, I'm sure,
the characters are
walking around in costume.
Research on Lu Xun would
fill a small library
and undoubtedly occupy a
great deal of shelf space
in the Asian division stacks.
However, the sensitivity
and complexity
of the writer himself are
frequently lost in the uses
that others have made of him.
He belonged to that
pivotal generation,
one foot in each world,
the old and the new.
Trained in the classical
tradition
and as a teenager embracing
western knowledge as it flooded
in from China -- into
China from Japan.
Japan had opened up
the western 1868.
And by 1902 when Lu Xun went
to Japan to study was well
on his way to becoming a
power in its own right.
Going to Japan thrust Lu Xun
outside of his own culture.
And I think that is what
probably enabled him to see
with an analytic eye and at
the same time from the inside
with deep understanding
of the culture
and intense moral commitment.
In Japan he enrolled in medical
school, but in his second year
and this is familiar to
anyone in Chinese studies,
his second year he
abandoned the career,
that career, for literature.
Explaining what the Chinese
people most needed was not
to have their bodies healed, but
to have their spirits changed.
And many scholars have
perceived this medical metaphor.
So, the second part of
my lecture is to talk
about how my work asked a new
question about this metaphor
and what is it that makes my
interpretation and my approach
to these stories rather unique?
Of enumerable scholars who
have addressed the issue
of his diagnosis of the
Chinese spiritual illness
and his crisis, his
analysis of its causes.
Almost without exception
they focus on his critiques
of Chinese society and
its Confucian roots.
This is a logical outcome
of his explicit social concerns
is an essential line of inquiry,
but it also has some
limitations.
My work asks this,
"If Lu Xun thought
that he could change the
spirits of the Chinese people
with literature, did he have
an implicit psychological model
of healing?"
Does the concept -- doesn't
the concept spirit also have
inner dimensions.
I have asked, "Did
he have a diagnosis,
an etiology that is an
analysis of the causes,
a notion of the therapeutic
process?
If he thought he could make
changes in the spirits,
he must have had
some idea of how.
And a vision of the cured state.
And what might one discover
by thinking of spiritual cure
as having a psychological
dimension."
Not surprisingly, if
you pose a new question,
you usually get new insights.
But nevertheless I do want to
say that my work is in addition
to a lot of other wonderful
work that's been done and on
which it certainly depends.
So how am I going to answer
my question about the,
you know, the methodology?
Why this is different.
And I start with a
personal experience.
This study began when I was a
college sophomore in a course
in modern Chinese
literature in translation.
I think we probably read
his most iconic stories,
certainly true story of
Ah Q. Undoubtedly "Regret
for the Past," I don't remember.
But I do know that when I
read one of his stories,
"The New Year Sacrifice,"
[inaudible] it was
as someone had like hit me
in the stomach and I thought,
"What has happened here?"
I had never been to China and I
don't think I really knew anyone
who was Chinese or
certainly not well.
But I do answer that
question, but I'm not going
to answer it here today.
I do answer it in the book.
But the question, my own
reaction asked me to think both
about my reaction and in a
psychological sense and then
to begin to wonder about what
might be the psychological
dimensions within the stories.
Thus I was moved to ask
about the psychological model
by personal experience and I
admit, as a former director
of the Kluge Center,
it wasn't driven
by intellectual curiosity,
essentially, but
by my experience.
So therefore naturally the
study dwells very little
on Chinese history and culture
per se, although there's enough
to help a reader who's
not familiar with it.
Also, unlike most
studies, it's not primarily
about the man himself,
it's a study of text.
Of course we know the
man wrote the text,
so they obviously trace
back to the author himself,
but that's not the
central concern.
Similarly the work
decent is the content
and focuses on the structures.
That is, I look at the
patterns that repeat
in foremost of the stories.
And, in fact, it shows up
in all the famous ones.
But I'm not focuses primarily
on the content and content is
where most of the critics
direct their attention.
So my focus is elsewhere.
Lu Xun was known
for experimenting
with a variety of
narrative forms.
And so my attention to
structure and commonalities
in structure is not
exactly intuitive.
Nevertheless, careful
attention to structure reveals
that his stories are
very architectural.
There's an identifiable pattern
that repeats and attention
to this pattern turns out
to be highly productive.
Having identified the structure,
which I name, and here's sort
of the title, "A Bi-Polar Closed
System Viewed from the Outside."
Won't mean much in the
abstract, but there it is.
I tried to name the
structure in the context
of my two psychological
questions.
What did Lu Xun mean by
wanting to cure the spirits
of the Chinese people and
why did these stories move me
so deeply?
And that is where
the third element
in the presentation comes in.
The work of Carl Jung, who
along with Sigmund Freud,
who's much better known
in China, was the founder
of modern Chinese --
modern Western psychology.
You might be appropriately
suspicious
and it really is appropriate,
to wonder whether I might have
imposed a western framework
on a Chinese writer,
which would be a kind
of literary critical
cultural imperialism.
My answer to that, before you've
asked the question perhaps,
is that the pattern emerged
from close reading of the text,
which is another
distinctive feature.
Although I understand close
reading is coming back
into fashion.
But I used Carl Jung to
name what was immerging
from the text.
Not to impose a structure
that wasn't there.
And it's interesting, Carl Jung
and Lu Xun were contemporaries.
Jung was six years older.
But I'm not arguing influence.
I don't think there was
any direct influence.
They did participate in the same
sort of international zeitgeist,
but this is not a
study of influence.
I'm using Jung's concepts
of the psyche as a model
to explain what I was
finding in the text.
So I'll say my sort of third
element here, a word about Jung.
Jung viewed the human psyche
or the self as comprised
of the conscious mind
and the unconscious mind
in dynamic interaction.
The conscious mind is
primarily comprised of the ego.
The unconscious has two parts.
The personal unconscious and
the collective unconscious.
And needless to say
I'm simplifying
to be able to use this.
And we're not even interested
in the collective unconscious
for this talk, just the
personal unconscious.
According to Jung, the ego
is that part of the self
that we generally mean when
we say, "I is responsible
for the individual's
adaptation to the world
and is often mistaken and
sometimes mistakes itself
as being the whole,
which it is not."
Anyone who thinks about
their dreams is well aware
that there are other parts
of the mind that are not part
of the ego of a conscious mind.
The shadow, that is that
element of the unconscious,
is primarily made up of parts
that the psyche or the ego,
I'm sorry, the psyche -- the
parts that the ego has rejected.
It's in normal development some
parts of the self are favored,
approved and others
are rejected.
And what is favored tends
to be what, you know,
what your family likes,
what society favors.
Although not inevitably.
I think one reason that
adults find children
so charming is they say what
they think and what they mean
and they don't know
that some things are not
socially accepted.
They haven't learned that yet.
In normal human development the
shadow tends to go underground
out of awareness and
may even be forgotten.
But it can't be destroyed,
because it's part
of the whole person,
the whole self.
Being aware of the shadow
normally isn't a problem,
unless it intrudes on the ego,
perhaps by undermining
the egos conscious intent.
I'm sure this has
happened to all of you.
The ego may be surprised,
puzzled, angry,
when the shadow suddenly
speaks up or does something
that the ego was not aware
of or didn't approve.
And you're all probably familiar
with that example of
the Freudian slip.
When something pops
out of your mouth
and you think, who said that?
Couldn't have been me,
I didn't mean that.
Meant to hide it.
Well, that's sort of
your shadow speaking.
One way that the
disowned or shadow side
of the self may appear is
through what is called
projection of the shadow.
The psyche splits
off or disowns a part
of the self it considers
negative and then it tributes
that characteristic
to another person.
And then it may in
anger attack the other
as something outside of itself.
That is the psyche tries to
destroy the unwelcome part
of itself by embodying it in
some other person or object
out there and then attacking.
An amusing version of
this, I'm sure many
of you have heard this, is
the young child who comes
to school not having done
her homework and says
to the teacher, "The
dog ate the homework."
Right? The dog, who cannot
defend himself becomes the
scapegoat for the fact that
the child was negligent
and failed to do the assignment.
More seriously this image can
be projected onto entire groups.
Where the community contributes
some evil that has befallen it,
to a group usually with
insufficient power to fight back
and tries to contain it.
The internment of Japanese
Americans during World War II is
one very clear example
of political scapegoating
of an entire group.
And I'm sure it doesn't take
much imagination for you to look
around our current world
and see it still happening.
But although a part of
the self can be forgotten
and rendered unconscious,
it cannot be destroyed,
because it is part of the self.
Japanese Americans
were Americans,
not citizens of Japan.
And further Jung argued
and here he departed
from Freud significantly,
the psyche has a natural
impulse towards reintegration,
towards healing and
that some part of it,
some part of the psyche actually
wants the reintegration,
wants wholeness.
And I'm happy to say, as you
all know, that the wrong done
to Japanese Americans
was finally recognized
and the government
extends an apology.
That doesn't always
happen of course.
My book argues that one way
of viewing the spiritual
or psychological illness
that Lu Xun defined
as undermining China, is to
view his analysis as the split
of the shadow from the
ego within the whole self.
And healing as the reintegration
of these two parts.
He investigates this, this
idea in multiple domains,
that of the nation, the
community, the family
and the individual self
and imagines different
outcomes in each domain.
So one way to understand
the psycho dynamics
in the true story of Ah
Q, is to view the story
as an investigation into what
happens when the ego splits off
and expels the unwanted,
unacknowledged,
despised shadow side of the self
and then tries to destroy it?
Analyzing the true story of Ah Q
as a meditation on scapegoating,
defined in terms of these union
concepts, reveals dimensions
of the stories, the story
not previously noted.
So, I get to the fourth
part of my presentation.
I want to provide a few examples
that reveal how viewing the true
story of Ah Q as a medication
on scapegoating furthers our
understanding of the story.
The historical context
depicted in the stories
in 1911 revolution,
which is the revolution
that needed the last dynasty
and established the
Chinese republic.
The story was written ten years
after this event, so it was kind
of recent history, it depicts
incidents in the life of Ah Q,
that's the name of
the character.
A day laborer in a
small Chinese village.
A man who has a tendency
to get into fist fights,
which he usually loses.
But then he recasts his losses
as psychological victories.
When he oversteps the
boundaries of sexual propriety,
he's forced to leave
the village for town.
There he participates as
a low level accomplice,
in an act of petty thievery and
returns later to the village.
When ripples from the
coming revolution arrive
in his village he wants to
enlist in the revolution,
but the village elite
will have none of it.
They co-op the revolution,
claim it as their own.
The real social disruption
arrives in the form of a theft
of a very powerful
person's goods.
The authorities needing to
hold somebody responsible,
accuse Ah Q of the
crime and execute him.
Actually they shoot
him, not cut his throat.
Ah Q's signature
feature, the one he's know
for as a character, is
his stunning capacity
to turn physical defeat
into spiritual victory.
That is, when he's
defeated in some kind
of brawl he redefines
the experience,
such that he perceives himself
as having achieved
the upper hand morally
and psychologically.
At the time of its composition
Ah Q's capacity to turn defeat
into victory was
read allegorically.
Okay? It was read
as a representation
of China's failures to respond
to the challenges
brought by the west.
The notion that a nation
had a particular character,
a national character was
very current at the time,
and there was considerable
discussion
about China's national
character, what made it unique.
And then given the problems,
what deficiencies were
in its -- in this character.
Because if it was getting
beaten up by the west,
at least in its perception,
it must have been
deficient in some way.
Lu Xun, viewing himself as a
doctor rendering a diagnosis,
looked at what was wrong
with the patient, china,
in order to move the body
politic towards health
and a better future.
He himself declared
a few years later
that in creating the stories
he had attempted to --
he had attempted to describe
the souls of the Chinese people.
So, from the beginning Ah
Q was viewed as typical,
not just a literary character,
but typical of the
Chinese national character.
And what was considered
his essential feature,
was this capacity to
turn defeat into victory.
So, we should take a look
at what that actually means.
And I'm going to give you a few
of the simpler examples
from the story.
Simplest one, Ah Q was out
gambling, he's actually winning
for a change, winning a big pile
of silver, as it's described,
and suddenly a fight breaks
out, tables are overturned,
there's a lot of hub
bub and carrying on.
When he looks around
and comes to,
all of his winnings,
phht, caput.
Are gone. Initially he's a
little upset and bewildered
and then he slaps
his own face hard.
What is he doing?
Oh, I should say, slaps his
face and he feels better, okay,
makes him feel better.
He is, in fact, split his psyche
into the ego and the shadow.
Treats the ego as if
it were the whole self,
the one that gave the slap
and remember I mentioned
that Jung noted that frequently
the ego believes it is the
entire self.
So, this is not quite
as bizarre it may seem.
But then he disowns the part
of himself that felt the pain
and Lu Xun tells us, even though
his face is still tingling,
it works.
He feels better, he's
disowned the part
that was hit, defeat
into victory.
Another example.
Ah Q has ringworm scars.
I've never seen a ringworm scar,
but I gather they're
not very attractive.
And he's doesn't like them
and he's tabooed
all mention of them.
So, the very act,
if you think of it,
the act of tabooing itself
a part of your body that,
you know, is there,
is a way of trying
to disown or to dismiss it.
So, naturally when anyone
mentions the ringworm scars he
gets furious because
the very fact of having
to acknowledge the shadow
that has been rejected,
is what constitutes defeat.
So, he gets really angry.
So, just to be explicit as
we move to my next example,
scapegoating is envisioned
by Lu Xun and by the Jung,
proceeds by splitting
the psyche,
projecting the shadow a
negative part, what it regards
as negative, onto another group
and then attacking that person
for inciting their anger.
I should note that
Lu Xun himself
and this is really
interesting, about five years
after he wrote the story, had an
intuition that the story was not
about the past or the
present, as people said,
but that it was about
the future.
And even several
decades in the future.
So, he himself had a sense
that there was a
pattern going on here.
But he didn't obviously he was a
writer, not a literary critique,
so he didn't look
for the pattern,
but he sensed the pattern.
And I think the pattern shows
most clearly in a simple way,
in this famous incident
with a woman servant named
Ama Wu [assumed spelling].
Okay. So, at this point
in the story Ah Q's
sexuality is aroused
when he pinches a young nun.
I won't go into that part.
Offended though the nun hurls
a curse at him and she says,
"Ah Q, may you die sonless."
And not to have children
in a culture
that values filial
relationships is really bad.
However, Ah Q considers
the comment and thinks
that indeed he should
take a wife,
which is the social context
in which ones sexual appetite
or expression of it
is appropriate, right?
So, shortly after he's
sitting with a female servant,
they're both working
in the house of one
of these village elite, Ama Wu,
and she's innocently chatting
away about this and that.
And out of nowhere Ah Q says
to her, "Sleep with me."
She screams, goes running
from the room, big room,
big hullaballoo, and has
to be persuaded by the head
of the household that
she shouldn't think
about committing suicide.
Okay. So, Ah Q's ego
speaks of marriage.
His shadow speaks of
sexual intercourse.
When the man of the house
comes after Ah Q, big step,
to beat him for this
gross transgression,
Ah Q does not understand
that he himself has initiated
the uproar.
He thinks, like, "Hmm, wonder
what's happening here."
That is to say he has so
disowned the shadow self,
which caused the uproar, that
he doesn't even recognize it
as his own self.
Further, and this is
important, the woman,
who has in no way provoked
his proposition, she's just,
you know, jibber
jabber, chatter, chatter,
behaves as if she were
in fact responsible,
so contemplates suicide,
which is the socially
appropriate response.
Ah Q has -- Lu Xun has
revealed that Ah Q,
having disowned his sexuality,
has projected it onto Ama Wu,
and she is merely the recipient
of the shadow projection.
But she responds as if
the society will agree
that she's to blame.
In fact, that she is the --
so that he has attempted
to scapegoat her.
Lu Xun made the same
argument in another story,
which is much overlooked,
"Soap."
That is he also showed there
that society has encouraged men
to disown their sexuality,
project their desires onto women
and then accuse women
of having incited it.
Certainly he viewed this as
an issue of power as well,
but also in psychological terms.
So, Ah Q's behavior
only seems exaggerated,
because he masks the normal
covers that society creates
to hide it, to hide the -- to
hide the shadow projection.
So, my example of the Japanese,
there was some equivalence made,
they were dangerous, because
they might have connections
with the Japanese government
that was attacking us, etc. So,
there's usually an excuse
to mask the projection.
But in Ah Q, the story of
Ah Q, there's no excuse,
he doesn't know he
needs to make one.
When the revolution
comes to the village,
the same scapegoating process
is enacting on the social scale,
on the societal scale.
And it's interesting seeing the
perils between Ah Q's behavior
and that of the village elite
is particularly important.
Okay, why is it important?
Because over the decades the
critics have understood Ah Q is
a type, as I said, And trying to
determine what he is typical of,
have looked outside of
the story for answers.
It was particularly a
challenge for critics working
under [inaudible] constraints,
because Chairman
[inaudible] had praise Ah Q
in such extraordinary -- I'm
sorry, has praised Lu Xun
in such extraordinary ways.
So, in the context
of class struggle,
which I guess you will remember
as one of these major elements
in that period, Ah Q,
the peasant is he a good
figure, he's a peasant?
Or a bad figure?
And then how to explain
his cowardice
in turning physical
defeat into moral victory.
And what was he typical of, was
he typical of China before 1949
or was he in some way
typical, could he be typical
of the great life that
happened after 1949.
So, it created a
lot of problems.
I'm sure the critics did
very well in trying to deal
with what had been
set up for them.
But even critics not laboring
under such ideological
constraints, looked outside
of Lu Xun's text to try
to understand typicality.
And in a way I would say the
writer has thrown them a curve,
because in naming the story,
the true story of Ah Q,
you're naturally going to
focus on Ah Q. But if you look
at the entire story through
the lens of ego and shadow
and the whole self, then you can
see that his behavior and that
of the other villages,
are in fact just the same.
That they too are trying to
turn defeat into victory,
except they have more power
so they can sometimes do it
in the external world.
So, few more words
about how that works.
In the story Lu Xun treats the
revolution in [inaudible] terms,
and you may not have
noticed this.
When the revolutionary
arrives, power holders,
that is the social ego, try to
coop it, they get the badges,
they get the banners, you
know, all of the paraphernalia.
And managed to remain in power.
But in the text when Lu
Xun describes them he notes
that there are bad
revolutionaries
who are always off somewhere
else, never seen, you only hear
about them, and they are out
there really disrupting society.
He never calls the local
elite good revolutionaries,
but the others are
bad revolutionaries.
So, he's already set up a
kind of union dynamic there.
What's so wonderful
about this technique is
that within the text in
keeping them never dramatized,
they're always sort
of like off stage,
you hear about them second
hand through something.
It's kind of mimicking the way
in which the shadow is actually
experienced psychologically.
So, those of you
who know literature
in this period often know that,
you know, have a clash of good
and evil, but Lu Xun
is swifter than that.
He doesn't set it up that way.
When the revolution actually
does reach the village,
Ah Q tries to sign up
and he's shushed away.
Then a serious theft occurs.
Which may or may
not have been --
we don't know who committed
the revolutionaries or who.
But there's a serious theft.
The captain, now he's from
the town, who's in charge
with solving, not just this
crime, but several others,
hasn't been able to
solve any of them.
And he's feeling
pretty embarrassed
and he's probably
worried about his job,
although is ay that's
my addition.
Lu Xun doesn't actually
say that.
So, he has -- he looks at Ah Q
and he says, "Aha,
got a culprit."
People think he's been
a thief, you know,
there he is, let's nail him.
He's clearly innocent,
he even has an alibi,
most of the villagers
believe he's not a thief
who will steal again.
There is a trial,
barely a trial,
and he's executed
as a public example.
So, I want to go back
to my earlier metaphor.
This is very much the example of
the dog that ate the homework.
While it is very plausible
that the dog indeed could
have eaten the homework,
it's the least likely
explanation.
And, so, Ah Q is a
very plausible thief
and he's illiterate and not
very clear headed and is
about as good at defending
himself as the dog would be.
Looking at the story through a
[inaudible] lens then reveals
the conceptual unity
of the plot.
The early part focused on
Ah Q and the latter part.
And it also makes apparent
that the same psychodynamic is
reenacted by the other clans
in the village and one
of the great things
about this story is
reading again for this talk,
I saw again, it's not
just that it's enacting
within the village, but it's
also enacted within the town.
Keep seeing more things.
So that when those at the
higher level of power are faced
with a crime and a problem
that they can't deal with,
they resort to scapegoating
as well, just as Ah Q has,
as the local elite have and
now the people in the town.
So he's executed because they
can't find the real culprit.
Almost overlooked and I'll
just say a few more things
about Ah Q, is that Lu Xun
has provided six different
perspectives on this execution.
And I'll just name them.
You can look for
yourself at a later point.
The soldiers who come to arrest
Ah Q, the judge who presides
at the trial, the man
whose goods are stolen,
who naturally just wants
them back, the local --
and he's related
to the local elite.
The captain who arrests him.
Ah Q himself, he has
a perspective on this,
which might surprise you.
And the general population
witnessed the execution.
Also often overlooked are the
last two paragraphs of the story
and there's a lot in there,
but I just want to know here
that Lu Xun makes very clear
that the bad revolutionaries,
as it were, are still out there.
So, executing the scapegoat, it
may give you temporary relief,
but the real folks
are still there.
I just want to mention
one other dimension,
which I certainly
can't go into here,
but I do go into in the book
in some detail is there's
another really important critic,
Rene Girard, who spends a lot
of his several books talking
about violence and how
human societies try
to contain and prevent violence.
And his focus is on different
stages in scapegoating.
What tends to cause it,
how the process unfolds,
who the victims usually are,
etc. And his very useful
insight is that scapegoating
at a societal level tends
to occur when the rule
of law is not in place.
This is not to say that
there are no scapegoats
when you have the rule of law.
But that when the society, as a
society goes into scapegoating,
it tends to be because the
rule of law is weakened.
And, of course, what
is a revolution,
but a destruction
of the rule of law.
It's interesting, Girard
mentions four stages
in scapegoating, but if
you look carefully at Ah Q,
not only has Lu Xun built
into his story all four,
but they're really two more.
And I won't get into that.
It's sort of based on what
Girard was looking at.
So, when I looked at this
and I saw this pattern
of scapegoating, and remembered
that Lu Xun had intuited
that there was a
pattern in his story,
but he didn't know what it
was, I'm wondering if that's
in fact what he intuited.
My final point, which
is to say something
about using a union
interpretation as a way
of looking not just at this
story and other stories.
I called it a bi-polar
closed system feud
from an exterior point.
Right, that's of the
abstract description.
And just briefly to take
a look at how that shows
up in the true story of Ah
Q. I should say in Ah Q,
no matter what you have in
other stories, it always seems
to be more complicated
and intricate,
but just briefly that pattern.
Closed system, okay.
The events that I've
outlined take place
within a narrative frame
where you have a narrator
at the beginning and the -- an
overt narrate in the beginning.
And the story begins, that is
the narrator's story begins
after Ah Q has been executed.
So, there's a temporal
closure, a temporal circle.
If you juxtapose Ah Q
and the village elite,
you have the bi-polarity there.
And, of course, it changes, as
I said, the story's complicated,
but there's bi-polarity
through all.
And then the external view,
initially it's the narrator,
but I think primarily
it's the use
of irony throughout the story
that creates the
external vision.
And I haven't even
talked about the irony.
I certainly didn't have
time to get that in.
So, that pattern informs Ah Q,
it's in, I think I mentioned,
all the major stories.
It's in four images
in the preface,
to the first collection
of short stories.
It's in a Mad Man's Diary.
I mentioned this is
the 100th anniversary.
It's in -- that pattern informs
the New Year's sacrifice,
which is the story that got me
at the beginning
when I was a student.
I just realized as I was writing
this that I read the story
at about the same age that Lu
Xun went to Japan and I thought,
"Oh, yeah," that's when
your mind gets opened.
In the book I show that
interpreting this structure
through Jung's conceptual
framework shows
that indeed Lu Xun
had an implicit model
of psychological
illnesses and its causes.
That in some venues
he could imagine
that therapeutic process
unfolding, although not
in the true story of Ah Q, and
that he even imbedded in several
of his stories a
vision of the cure.
And, again, those of you
who know the literate know
that in terms of the
social environment,
there wasn't a vision of
the cure, but within the --
he could envision it within the
family, not always, sometimes,
but he could envision
it in the family
and he could envision
it in the private self.
And that's all encoded in
the structure of the stories
as you read them
through a union lens.
So, the union approach combined
with a focus on the structure,
gives new meaning to Lu
Xun's decision to take
up the profession of
literature in his hope
of healing the spirits
of the Chinese people.
So, I'll stop there.
I think we have time
for questions.
Although I was, yep, little bit.
I meant to have more.
Yes.
>> Thank you very much.
I just want to add that
[inaudible] architects,
[inaudible] anonymous seem
to be also applicable here,
because [inaudible]
society, as you know.
>> Right.
>> I'm sure you [inaudible]
rejection of the,
I don't know, [inaudible]
psyche.
And how that would be
part of the social malady
of [inaudible], I was wondering
how much Lu Xun addressed
himself to that particular
sexist component
of the [inaudible]?
>> Well, it's really
interesting because he --
and thank you for that
comment, because, you know,
I wondered about Anima and
Animus and I had so much to do
and I was trying to
pull it all together,
so I decided I'm not going
to go down that route.
But he really thought
a lot about the role
of women in that society.
And he thought about it
I would say differently
from a lot of his colleagues.
He has a famous essay
that's called, "What happens
after Nora leaves home?"
Alluding to Henrik
Ibsen, "A Doll's House."
And he argues that in China she
leaves home, either she's going
to have to -- either she's
going to starve to death
or she's going to
have to return.
And he has a story, which
follows the structure,
but which I argue
really ask the question,
people are always trying to
figure out what his answer was.
I think the story, it's
called, "Regret for the Past
in English," what it
looks at that question.
But of great interested,
a greater interest I think
is his story, "Soap."
Which was usually overlooked
because it doesn't have
that overtly, that
kind of social content,
that social critical content.
But in "Soap" he creates
a woman who is married
to an old fashioned man.
I won't try to go
into the whole story.
But she figures out in the
course of a dinner conversation
that he's been oogling a
young woman on the street
and directing his
sexual attentions to her.
She says nothing until for
various reasons he goes
after the child.
It's a very good view
of a woman really.
And then she comes
out after him.
But what Lu Xun has
done is he's given in --
at a time when most of the
male writers were using women,
female figures as part of their
argument about social realities,
so kind of using them as
tokens, he has created a woman
who speaks her own
mind in her own voice,
terrifies her husband,
because he's not expecting,
because usually she's
very behaving.
And has actually written in a
character who is as powerful
in rereading the
Confucian text, you know,
which you see in other stories.
But the woman rereading what
gets called the performative
text, the way people behave,
through a whole new lens,
and this is one of the
stories that shows healing,
because after her
husband recovers
from this attack,
she uses the gift.
He's brought here a gift of soap
and it implies that, in fact,
she has succeeded in
redirecting his sexual interest
to her person.
And there's a little detail
in there that after she uses
that for six months,
a new aroma pops up.
Sandalwood soap.
And thanks to my wonderful
research assistant,
Dushaya [assumed spelling], I've
understood, came to understand
that sandalwood soap was a
special, more expensive soap.
So, she went.
It's not -- they both win.
And that's the point, that when
ego and shadow come together
and the knowledge is integrated,
everybody wins, in fact,
but it's one of his best,
most well crafted stories.
It's not an excess word in it.
And it's just --
it's jut brilliant.
It's really, it's
really brilliant.
So, thank you for that question.
>> Is there a [inaudible]
solution
or therapy in [inaudible]?
>> No. Because what happens--
so the way I looked at
the stories is I looked
at the stories that seemed
to function primarily --
they seemed to be
mostly about what happens
at the national state.
And that's Ah Q and
another national level,
another story of medicine.
And then what tends to happen
at the community level,
what may happen within the
family and what may happen
within the self, at
the national level
that shadow figure ends up dead.
Community level the shadow
figure often ends up dead,
but no one has killed
the person.
It's been neglect,
it's been poverty,
it's been all the things that
are in the social system.
At the family level a lot of
times doesn't work very well,
but he does have -- this story,
"Soap" that I've talked about,
where you have spiritual healing
and then there's another story,
which people argue is
influenced by Freudian thinking.
These early ones I'm
pretty sure were not -
that's a longer story.
But anyway, where the person's
encounters their shadow
in a dream and takes in the
knowledge of their own evil
and then very very
subtly he shows
that they've changed
just a little bit.
So you get the way that
they behave at work,
the certain arrogance and,
"Boy, our family's great,
we do this, that and the other."
And at the end when he absorbs
the knowledge of his own --
we would say evil, Chinese
wouldn't say evil --
his own shadow.
He's more humble
and compassionate.
But it's very subtle.
So, no, at the national --
at that national level shadow's
finished, executed, killed.
Yeah, Mary Jane.
>> Thank you, [inaudible].
Fascinating.
Did Lu Xun have the concept
of the function of literature?
In other words, when he
was writing was he thinking
of making society look at
itself, individuals look
at themselves, or was he trying
to change the existing
format of literature?
Did it have a function beyond
the literary the telling
of a story in terms
of the society?
Did he see his literature
as an instrument of change
or self-recognition or?
>> Yeah, no, his main
ambition was to change society
and to change the
way people thought.
Because, and I'm going
to make a gross statement
about the Chinese culture
that somebody can
probably shoot me for,
but I think there's a tendency
there to think that the thought,
the way you think is the
central part that's going
to help change the world, the --
I'm trying to think
of the language.
Chairman [inaudible] thought
to change the thinking,
so you change the exterior.
I think westerners tend
to change the exterior
and hope the thought
will follow.
But anyway, yes, his intention
was to change the society,
to change it by revealing
what was wrong and looking
at those patterns and
showing that the patterns
that everybody had
been following
for who knows how long.
I mean, obviously he's
only living in a --
but, certain time, but the
tradition, as he met it
in the early 20th century, to
show that some of the things
that people said about humanity
and filial piety and the things
that come from the -- now, of
course, I'm blanking on some
of the other language -- that
if you looked under the hood,
as it were, what
you saw was cruelty
and misery and inhumanity.
And that wasn't necessary.
I think that was the point.
It wasn't necessary and
therefore, you could change it
and things would be better.
But you can't change it if
you don't know what it is.
So, he's trying to put it on
the table and say, "Hey, look,
you thought this was so
great, it's killing people."
I mean, I'm being
sort of dramatic here.
So, that was the intent.
Initially he thought he --
and this sort of collapsed --
his first hope in taking up
literature was he was going
to do translation and
that if society --
and, of course, we're
just talking
about an intellectual elite,
right, we're not talking
about the whole society.
That if the leadership could see
in new ways then they
could do things in new ways
and it would be helpful to have
western knowledge coming in,
because it gives you not
necessarily that you adopt it,
because he was smart enough not
to know you don't
adopt things wholesale,
but it gives you an
angle of vision to look
at what your own culture is
and then you can see
what needs to be changed.
And although he doesn't talk
about what works, you know,
there's always what works.
So, he's trying to
heal the illness,
it's not cut off a working
limb in some way, yeah.
I think, oh, maybe
last question.
>> How would you say that
Lu Xun's message is relevant
for today?
>> Oh, that's a tricky one.
>> There's a plant
in the audience.
>> Yeah, there's a
plant in the audience.
Well, I'll say a couple
things and I'm not going to --
I don't think it's my place as a
westerner who hasn't spent a lot
of time in China to talk
about what China
should and shouldn't do.
But I will say that
it's really important
to understand scapegoating.
It happens all the time.
It's happening in our
current political culture.
You know, rather
than paying attention
to what are the real causes
of things, it's much easier
to point at -- there's a lot
pointing at groups right now
and say, "They're
causing the problem."
And maybe a few people
in the group may be causing
the problem, but a few people
in your own group are
also causing problems.
So, it's a lot easier
to scapegoat others
than to actually try to figure
out what's really going wrong,
what the causes are and then
heaven forbid actually do
something about it.
So, to me the whole -- and I
will say in my life the learning
to understand that
I too have a shadow.
I do things, say
things occasionally,
try not to say things, a little
easier, but do things that come
out of, you know, a part
of myself that's not --
that's not my best self.
And the trick, of course, is
to catch it before you do it
so that you can integrate that
knowledge into who you are
and become a more
whole, more integrated,
usually more compassionate
person.
Because once you see,
I'll just -- this is --
when I was in graduate school I
discovered in a moment of fear
that I get very belligerent
when threatened
and I might even be
capable of murder.
I don't know that, but I've been
in other situations
where I've wondered.
If I, you know, had.
So, that's really
useful knowledge.
No, I'm not going
to shoot you all.
It's -- it helps you understand
that other people, right,
who don't have the resources
of intellect and money and time
and all the privileges
that we have,
and maybe have a gun available,
can fire off really fast.
And that doesn't mean
somehow you're not responsible
for what you do, but
it complicates it
and I think it makes
you more compassionate
and we can certainly use more
compassion, more understanding.
Which doesn't mean, as I said,
it doesn't mean you're not
responsible, but you see more
and you're probably
a little more humble.
And I say in the
shadow of the capital,
a little more humility
and self-reflection.
So, we a little after 5 and
I was supposed to stop at 5?
Let's --
>> Thank you, Dr.
Brown, wonderful.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.